اسمي YULA وأنا فنان ومخرج
سينمائي في تورونتو وأنا أيضًا
مواطن إسرائيلي غادرت إسرائيل منذ 23 عامًا وأنا
أعيش في كندا منذ ذلك الحين، هذا هو جواز
سفري الإسرائيلي وهو هويتي الإسرائيلية
وبطاقة الإعفاء من الجيش
لم أخدم في الجيش
الأسبوع الماضي، لقد قدمت طلبًا للتخلي عن
جنسيتي الإسرائيلية في
القنصلية هنا في تورونتو،
ولم يكن قرارًا اتخذته باستخفاف، لقد
كنت أفكر فيه لفترة طويلة
في الواقع منذ اللحظة التي علمت فيها  عن
التاريخ الحقيقي للمكان الذي
نشأت فيه، التاريخ الذي لم يتم تدريسه لنا
في المدارس أو حتى التحدث عنه أثناء
إقامتي هناك حتى الأسبوع الماضي في
القنصلية، لقد كانت عملية طويلة حقًا
واستغرقت عقدين من الزمن، نعم فعلت ذلك
ذلك رداً على الهجوم الإسرائيلي المروع
على غزة،
ولكن بما أن هذه ليست المرة الأولى التي
تقصف فيها إسرائيل غزة، فلماذا الآن لماذا هذه
اللحظة
لأن عدد
الضحايا قد وصل إلى
أبعاد كارثية وعلى الرغم من أننا في وقف
مؤقت لإطلاق النار أو توقف مؤقت أو  كل ما
تريد أن تسميه
الآن، يبدو أنه لن ينتهي في
أي وقت قريب سواء أدركت إسرائيل ذلك
أم لا، كل هذا الموت يؤذي
شعبها أيضًا أثناء طفولتي في
إسرائيل، لقد عشت حربين كبيرتين،
إحداهما كانت الأولى.  حرب الجولف
الانتفاضتين الفلسطينيتين
26 تفجيرًا انتحاريًا
شهدت أحدها بنفسي، وكانت مدينتي
الواقعة على الحدود اللبنانية
تتعرض للقصف يومًا بعد يوم طوال
طفولتي بأكملها. شاركت في
عشرات التدريبات تعلمت
التمييز بين
الصواريخ الصادرة والواردة  فقط حتى أتمكن من البقاء
في السرير، أضف بضع
دقائق أخرى وخلال كل ذلك
كانت الرسائل في الأخبار وفي الصحف وفي كل مكان من حولنا أن
هذا أمر طبيعي لأننا يهود وكل
من حولنا يريد
إبادتنا، لماذا  هل أفعل هذا الآن لأنه
أصبح من الواضح بالنسبة لي الآن أكثر من أي وقت مضى أن
السلام في إسرائيل ليس هو الهدف. أشعر
أنها نوع الدولة التي لا تهتم
بشعبها وأنا لا
أتحدث حتى عن كل هذا التعذيب.  الإساءة والإذلال التي
يتعرض لها الفلسطينيون
في الضفة الغربية في غزة أو الفلسطينيين الذين
يحملون الجنسية الإسرائيلية التي
تحب إسرائيل استخدامها كنوع من الدليل على
أنها ليست دولة منفصلة. أنا أتحدث
عن الطريقة التي تعامل بها إسرائيل
شعبها هي كيان  مبني على
تسلسلات هرمية حيث ترتبط قيمة الشخص
وإنسانيته مباشرة
بهويته في هذا النوع من المجتمع حيث
يتم تصنيف الناس ووضعهم ضمن
تسلسل هرمي
مثل الإساءة والتنمر هي الطريقة التي
يستغل بها الناس إحساسهم بالتفوق
والاستحقاق ويؤكدون أنفسهم
عندما  لقد رفضت الخدمة في الجيش عندما كان
عمري 18 عامًا، ولم يكن ذلك بسبب أي نوع من
الوعي السياسي، فقد كنت أعيش في
بلدة صغيرة ولم يكن لدي أي فكرة عما كنت
أفعله، بل لأنني أدركت
الطاقة الرجولية العنيفة التي تذكرتها
منها.  لقد تعرفت على المتنمرين في طفولتي
في هذا النظام الجديد الذي
كان من المتوقع مني أن أخدمه وشعرت بأن
كياني كله يقاومه، سافرت
عبر الضفة الغربية بجواز
سفري الكندي، مررت عبر
نقاط التفتيش ورأيت الجنود وكيف
كانوا  أعامل
الناس اعتمادًا على المكان الذي ينتمون إليه،
رأيت المجموعتين المزدوجتين من الطرق، واحدة
لليهود الإسرائيليين وواحدة للفلسطينيين،
وطوال كل ذلك،
لم يكن الأشخاص الذين التقيت بهم سوى طيبين معي، وعندما
عبرت الحدود عائدًا إلى إسرائيل،
شاهدت
الأخبار وكانوا يتحدثون عن نفس
الأشخاص الذين كانوا يطعمونني ويساعدونني في
العثور على طريقي
كحيوانات غير عقلانية بلا قلب تريد قتلي، أنا
مندهش حقًا من أن الأمر استغرق مني
سنوات عديدة للوصول إلى هذه النقطة
وكنت  أشعر بالحرج قليلاً ولكني أعتقد أنني
أعرف لماذا استغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً، حيث
تنفق إسرائيل الكثير من الوقت والمال وتغني
شعبها ضد بعضهم البعض،
وأفراد العائلة والأصدقاء والجيران، وهذا القرار
سيؤثر على حياتي، وقدرتي على
زيارة المكان الذي نشأت فيه.
سيؤثر ذلك على علاقتي مع
عائلتي وعلاقاتي مع الأشخاص
الأقرب إلي لا أريد أن أفعل أي شيء حيال
ذلك لا أريد أن أكون جزءًا منه ولكن
هذا القرار
ضروري لقد انتهيت وآمل ذلك  سوف
يرسل رسالة وآمل أن
يفكر الأشخاص الآخرون في موقفي في
فعل الشيء
نفسه